this is Chris no wait that's not average
enough
James okay this is James
he just graduated with a bachelor's
degree and thirty thousand dollars in
student loan debt which is a rounded
average amount of what most graduates in
the US end up with on which he pays a
five percent interest rate which is
again pretty average
and this is
Mary Mary also took out the exact same
loan James's payment plan allowed him to
be debt free in 10 years while Mary's
repayment plan meant that she ended up
owing more money after paying towards
the loan for a decade the Supreme Court
is about to decide the fate of President
Biden's plan to forgive up to twenty
thousand dollars in student debt but
that is by no means the only big thing
that the Biden Administration has done
on student debt one of his other moves
that was actually announced the same day
as mass stat cancellation got much less
attention but is arguably going to make
a much bigger difference in the long run
for Student Loan borrowers the other big
part of Biden's plan will change how
Mary James and most other current and
future borrowers will repay their
student loans here's how
let's start with James on this loan his
monthly payment would be 318
and this is his payment schedule it's
like a mortgage or car loan where the
interest essentially gets paid off first
so his first month James owes a hundred
and twenty five dollars in interest
so the remaining 193 dollars of his
monthly payment goes towards the loan's
original amount the principal which then
lowers his total balance
it's called amortization
each month less of his monthly payment
goes towards interest and more towards
the principal those monthly payments
make his total amount paid go up and his
balance owed go down
until at the end of 10 years he's paid
off the loan paying thirty eight
thousand dollars in total
James's experience is what repayment
looks like for more than 40 percent of
all student loan borrowers while he
can't afford those monthly payments on
his sixty thousand dollar a year salary
that's too much for Mary who makes
thirty thousand dollars a year so she
did what nearly 40 percent of borrowers
do and went on to an income-based
repayment plan which lowered her monthly
payment to around 68 a month
but with amortization she still owes
that 125 dollars the first month since
it's the same loan as James
but Mary's monthly payment is less than
that meaning there's nothing to go
towards the loan's principle and her
balance owed goes up
her monthly payments only go towards the
interest which makes her total amount
paid go up but also her balance
at the end of 10 years Mary has paid
eight thousand dollars towards her
student loans but she still owes more
than thirty eight thousand dollars this
situation is a common one the exact
number of marries is unknown but a Pew
survey found that two in five borrowers
owe more than they originally took out I
hear from people every single day whose
current balance is even after they've
been paying off their student loans for
5 10 15 years are larger than the
balance they started with
the income driven repayment programs are
set up to only last 20 or 25 years
so in theory people like Mary will have
paid sixteen thousand dollars after two
decades and her then 53 000 balance
would be forgiven but a government
report found that of all the borrowers
at that stage only 11 percent would be
eligible for forgiveness it shows how
common it is that so few people are able
to complete these programs what's
uncommon is successfully completing the
income driven repayment program as it
was designed that's what's uncommon it
if they miss one payment they become
unenrolled in the program they could
have not submitted their income
re-certification information which is
necessary every single year or there
could have been some data issue where a
payment to a servicer did not get
recorded properly and as a result you
are no longer eligible to be part of
this program
I've been to Mary she would be on the
hook for her entire balance with all
that built up interest
re-enrolling in the program is her only
path to earned forgiveness this is
something President Biden's student loan
plan attempts to fix
under the new system any extra interest
not covered by Mary's monthly payment
would be forgiven so her balance
wouldn't increase
the new plan also changes the rules
around who qualifies and lowers their
monthly payments Mary with her thirty
thousand dollar a year salary would
likely have no monthly payment even
James would be eligible for a smaller
monthly payment
and dramatically if someone uh let's say
Robert has twelve thousand dollars or
less in undergraduate loans they would
have their debt forgiven after 10 years
of small or sometimes zero dollar
payments no as an undergraduate loan
today
or in the future whether for Community
College or a four-year College will have
to pay more than five percent of their
discretion and income to re to repay
their loan so this is really Shifting
the boundaries between what counts as a
loan and what counts as a grant this
proposal probably goes farther than
President Biden intended to go at least
while he was campaigning for president
but that largely reflects the reality
that nothing was getting done in
Congress on this issue and he felt for
political or economic reasons or other
reasons that he needed to move forward
on an executive action basis or through
using powers that were available to him
under existing law Powers not everyone
agrees he should be able to use for this
because President Biden couldn't get his
radical agenda through Congress he is
dismantling the federal student loan
program and pushing Democrats free
College Plan by executive Fiat
these changes go into effect in July
regardless of how the Supreme Court
rules on debt forgiveness this plan is
also going to be expensive one report
found that while forgiveness would cost
the U.S nearly 500 billion dollars over
the next 10 years the changes to income
driven repayment would cost 141 billion
or more as more borrowers take advantage
of the program
while forgiveness is criticized as
solving a problem for the past without
creating a future solution this plan
looks to change the way student loans
are handled going forward
so Mary doesn't end up owing sixty
thousand dollars for her thirty thousand
dollar degree
[Music]
foreign